la pologne au travail et maintenant la
pêche l'accalmie avant la reprise des
discussions
l'invité monsieur jean françois poncet
là messieurs bonsoir les grévistes de la
baltique ont repris le travail ce matin
au terme d'un conflit croissant qui a
ébranlé la pologne tout est maintenant
de savoir si les fissures qu'on l'a cru
sentir sont tout à fait colmater ou bien
si elle dissimule d'autres craquements à
venir le fait que moscou n'a pas zappé
la saison qu'on puisse dire la
cordillère la pravda à publie ce matin
un éditorial sévère sur ce qu'elle
appelle des éléments anti socialiste qui
sévissent en pologne et qui ont réussi à
pénétrer variant brise de relance pour
exploiter les difficultés économiques
sur place les choses sont allées bon
train les autorités ont même libérait
dès cet après-midi et cette couronne le
principal moteur du mouvement de défense
des ouvriers polonais considéré
pratiquement comme un dissident même
d'ailleurs que tous les membres du corps
ici nous voyons donc le travail
reprendre avenante et sur les deux
autres ports de la baltique
le gouvernement se déclare à tout faire
pour garantir comme promis la liberté
d'expression une ombre au tableau quand
même pour le bol un polonais la
poursuite de la grève dans huit mines de
charbon du bassin si des liens alors
comment tous ces événements ont ils été
vécue par les polonais aujourd'hui il
est temps maintenant de rejoindre notre
envoyé spécial à varsovie
philippe piat ce matin de longues files
s'allongeaient devant les kiosques à
journaux de varsovie un peu comme si les
polonais voulait s'assurer qu'ils
n'avaient pas rêver hier soir devant
leur téléviseur que la grève était bel
et bien finies les mauvaises langues
prétendent que même prix bouna loudoux
l'organe du parme
et bien vendu bourru diminue dans cette
foule aucune manifestation de joie mais
un soulagement certes les gens sentent
qu'il faut éviter tout ce qui pourrait
être pris comme une provocation au calme
à la maîtrise de soi que les grévistes
ont montré pendant une humaine répond
maintenant la retenue et la maturité
dans les réactions populaires en or il a
même pas entré à sotteville événement
chaque jour et hier avec la signature
des accords ma réaction c'est c'est la
joie et la satisfaction
maintenant évidemment il faudra locaux
d'un diplôme et du travail sérieux la
pologne doit rester sauf gagner on y lit
ces accords ne changeront pas cela mais
maintenant si j'ai besoin des deux
j'espère que les nouveaux syndicats
s'occuperont mieux de moi il fallait un
changement à cause du mécontentement
ces accords permettront un renouveau
pour la pologne pour moi ça ne changera
rien mais monfils lui il pourra mieux
travailler et gagner plus d'argent
du côté officiel on se dit tout aussi
satisfait mais on souligne le caractère
purement social et économique désaccord
entre le gouvernement et l'église
les syndicats y compris les syndicats
autonomes qui sont en train de se créer
accepte les principes du socialisme qui
est un système qui ne peut être contesté
en pologne
étant donné nos alliances et notre
situation géographique le nombre des
syndicats en pologne leurs
caractéristiques ne sont pas le problème
tout ce qui compte avec illzach thème
notre système et nos réalités
la vente soumise deux sentiments
dominent donc aujourd'hui en pologne
d'abord le soulagement que tout se soit
bien terminé à gdansk et ensuite un
optimisme prudent quant à l'avenir
en fait tout le monde ici sent bien
qu'on accomplit un saut dans l'inconnu
recherche la pologne reste comment un
pays socialiste mais il ne s'agira plus
du socialisme non orthodoxes dit alors
les polonais vers le père d'abord que ce
changement fondamental pour à résoudre
les graves problèmes ils connaissent car
par exemple fait que interminables pour
leurs achats
et puis les polonais espère que le culte
en voisin soviétique pourra tolérer
cette nouvelle réalité pour la leçon
minute lors bartoli comment est-ce que
moscou va prendre tout cela pour
l'instant la situation n'est pas très
claire il faut bien dire que les accords
verdun shgv ont contre toutes les
habitudes politiques mais il faut le
dire contre tous les dogmes politiques
en europe de l'est
prenez ces nouveaux chais syndicat
autolib horizons promis qu'ils ne
feraient pas politique mais une de leurs
premières le mandat était en face à
libérer des dissidents c'est bien un
geste politique
on se prenait ce qu'ils ont demandées
concernant l'assouplissement de la
censure si on tient parole si on ne
reprend pas d'un gauche qu on appris
d'un point la main droite
l'assouplissement de la simple la
censure ça veut bien dire qu'à certains
moments on va entendre s'élever des voix
qui sont pas les voix officielles ces
politiques
alors est ce que ces syndicats ne vont
pas faire plus ou moins figure de force
d'opposition c'est la question qu'on se
pose est un parti d'opposition ça ne
peut pas exister dans une démocratie
populaire c'est contraire au dogme
alors on a un peu l'impression que
monsieur direct qu'il le veuille ou non
il ne veut pas d'ailleurs fait un peu
figure aujourd'hui de
eric alors on se souvient un petit peu
trop de ce café pringuet ce que à votre
avis les choses vont se gâter
irrémédiablement entre moscou et
varsovie
écoutez je me garderai bien d'avancer
dans la mesure où les polonais les ducs
cette affaire ont fait preuve d'une
espèce de génie de la digue de la
négociation fait d'un mélange
extraordinaire de prudence et d'audace
alors ce génie va falloir qu'il le
montre si bien le gouvernement que les
syndicats les nuls un syndicat pour
démontrer aux soviétiques que toutes ces
nouveautés ne vont pas ruiner le camp
socialiste que ça ne va pas faire un
effet de contagion sur le reste des pays
socialistes et notamment sur la grille
par là des maillons faibles et que si
surprenante que ça soit et bien ça reste
le même si vous voulez dans les limites
du moindre mal bien georges pour ce
premier journal de septembre ce premier
journal la rentrée pour beaucoup d'entre
vous ont décidé de mettre un petit peu
d'ordre dans les esprits de ceux qui
étaient en vacances et de faire le point
sur les quatre grands sujets qui ont
agité l'actualité du mois d'août
la pologne est donc le premier d'entre
eux alors comment en images en est on
arrivé là georges de données alors il y
à la pologne pilia danse danse où tout
s'est joué finalement 18 jours de grève
une grève calmer avec un fond d'angoissé
car ici est dense que les grèves de 70
avait fini dans le sang cette fois tout
le monde garde son sang froid et mots et
loire guirec et hors dia qui avait
promis en 70 qui ne ferait jamais tiré
sur les juifs irakiens
il tente bien l'intimider un peu mais il
l'est même la négociation s'engage et
essai longue et si adam ce que tout se
joue alors que beenox n'est pas seul en
grève répétons le que dans toute la
pologne des grèves tournantes dure
depuis juillet paralysant partiellement
l'économie du pays mais dense avec ses
chantiers de construction navale est un
symbole et le chef des grévistes hier
vanessa devient un symbole lui aussi
très rapidement
très vite on comprend que si les
revendications formulées par ce petit
homme moustachu aboutisse et bien une
situation nouvelle sera créé et non pas
sur le seul lutteur baltique mais dans
tout cela le deuxième pouvoir qui est
bien entendu l'église le couvert
non-officiel en pologne est là présent
dans le débat
on va voir fait inhabituel la télévision
retransmettre une aube élite du cardinal
richard qui d'ailleurs copieusement
qu'avec caviardé mais les polonais
seront surtout sensible à la nouveauté
les ombres officielle ouverte aux vieux
cardinal
quant au pouvoir officiel celui là c'est
à dire au parti eh bien il est secoué
par un énorme remaniement des organismes
dits riches et c'est ainsi qu'à la danse
que les nouveaux négociateurs ont veillé
par le parti et le gouvernement les
nouveaux négociateurs se font plus
conciliant les négociations commencent à
progresser en ne crois pas encore tout à
fait du côté des grévistes
walesa reste ferme sur ses positions
autour du drapeau national on chante
l'hymne national le vieil hymne d'un
pays martyr non la pologne n'est pas
morte aussi longtemps que nous vivrons
et le 31 août hier l'impensable chemin
les 21 points de revendications sont
satisfaits l'accord est signé alors
toujours pour clarifier les esprits tout
ailleurs tout de suite après jour
interprèteront question de temps avec
des enquêtes des témoignages des
reportages des spécialistes une
révolution de jean pierre elkabbach donc
à 20h30
les réactions couleurs aujourd'hui en
france et notamment chez les syndicats
force ouvrière se réjouit de ce qui
s'est passé en cologne voilà 33 ans que
nous nous battons pour qu'il y ait de
pareils syndicat lab a dit bergeron sur
europe 1 c'est une victoire importante
dit aussi la cfdt mais qui reste fragile
puis certains membres de la cgt de la
radiotélévision reproche à jean le sait
dit de ne pas avoir apporté son soutien
aux grévistes polonais pourtant ce soir
à l'instant la cgt se réjouit
officiellement de cet accord
chez les politiques que approbation dans
la majorité au ps jean pierre
chevènement estimé qu'il s'agit là d'un
affranchissement bay steve par rapport à
la logique des blocs et l'humanité de ce
matin jugé les accords positive georges
marchais dans l'humanité de demain va
encore un petit peu plus loin puisque il
souhaite que des réformes de structure
et de gestion de l'économie favorisent
les travailleurs polonais alors qu'en
pense le gouvernement jean françois
poncet warfare 3 les observations
première observation vous savez que le
gouvernement a exprimé le souhait que ce
conflit trouve une solution à
l'intérieur du peuple polonais
conformément aux souhaits de sa
population
ce soit été exaucé c'est par le dialogue
par un accord à voie d'un accord que la
difficulté a été sur le monde et la
france s'en félicite
elle s'en réjouit parce que la pologne a
avec la france
une amitié très ça c'est très ancienne
elle s'en réjouit parce que c'est un
progrès de la démocratie et vous n'êtes
pas été partagée entre votre amitié pour
edward gierek et notre encouragement aux
ouvriers pour le lait bien je dirais que
deuxièmement c'est ma deuxième
observation ce résultat heureux il est
but
pas la maturité et à la sagesse dont ont
fait preuve à la fois la classe ouvrière
et le peuple polonais et les dirigeants
paul et puis je ferai une troisième
observation c'est que tout ceci est très
important pour ne pas le règlement mais
c'est aussi très important pour l'europe
et pour les relations entre l'est et
l'ouest
et j'observe que d'un côté comme de
l'eau on n'a pas cédé à la tentation qui
aurait été de faire d'un problème
intérieur polonais l'objet de
controverses ou d'une confrontation
entre l'est et l'ouest
et là aussi je m'en réjouis en tout cas
loin que personne n'a soufflé sur les
braises pour personne n'a soufflé sur
les braises de ce que chacun voyait bien
que ce qui est en cause était à la fois
décisif et alec four de l'intérêt du
peuple polonais mais vous n'avez jamais
eu peur un moment pour la détente
je crois que chacun dans cette affaire a
retenu un peu son souffle ce que la
france veut faire quelque chose pour
aider l'économie connaisse qui en a
vraiment besoin
il est clair que l'accord qui est
intervenu n'est pas un accord qui règle
tous les problèmes et en particulier le
problème est connu disposera la france
avec la pologne des relations
commerciales des relations de
coopération qui sont étroites
dans le cadre de ses relations elle a
déjà beaucoup fait pour la pologne et
bien entendu elle fera davantage croit
d'ailleurs qu'il faut pas non plus être
pessimiste à l'excès la pologne et à pic
a fait un gros effort industriels la
pologne est un pays dont le peuple
viennent démontrer sa détermination et
sa maturité
la pologne a des ressources notamment le
charbon
je crois que nous devons aider même si
faire confiance aux labels mais être
aussi généreux que l'on était tout de
suite les allemands de l'ouest
je vous dirais que nous l'avons déjà dit
mais nous n'avons pas fait beaucoup
de bruit nous relations la pologne je le
disais sont des relations très anciennes
très amicale et notre coopération est
très étroite
est ce qu'on peut savoir ce qui s'est
dit dans les messages que son échange et
valérie rld et un élan qui n'est pas
habituel de révéler le contenu
de tels messages mais je bouge et on
peut vous dire c'est que ces messages ne
contredisent pas ce deuxième volet mais
au terme de tout ce qu'on entendait dans
votre bouche on a l'impression que vous
allez conforter un régime un système qui
n'est pas le vôtre n'est pas celui que
vous souhaitez vous restera en france
pendant le socialisme au le problème
n'est pas trop forte et nous avons vous
le savez des relations avec un grand
nombre de régimes dans le monde si nous
devions en avoir de relation qu'avec les
régimes que nous approuvons ses
relations seraient réduites en ce qui
concerne la pologne relations ce double
sera forte de cette amitié qui existe
j'ajoute que après ceux qui viennent se
passent elles se renforcent du désir de
voir ce progrès de la démocratie
consolidée en classe lui la vraie raison
de votre présence ici ce n'est pas la
peau lainée mais c'était l'actualité de
fallait vous interrogez avions choisi de
vous ai interrogé sur l'ouganda pour
savoir un peu ce qu'a fait la france
depuis ces images tout le monde a encore
en mémoire de ce reportage que nous
avions effectué le 25 juin tout d'abord
je prends les premiers en france et puis
à nouveau début août un reportage de
philippe gassot donc je vous invite à
revoir à nouveau un extrait l'ouganda
banda donc perdre des prestataires de
famine c'était au coeur de l'épée début
août et je crois que ça a dérangé
beaucoup de confiance semaines après la
mise en oeuvre des moyens français en
ouganda les deux hélicoptères destinés à
ça y est les populations isolées du nord
et du nord-ouest ont véritablement
commencé leur ronde les entrepôts de
sortie sont pratiquement plein
paradoxalement les organisations
installé sur place depuis le début de la
famine répugne à fournir des vivres que
pourrait transporter les hélicoptères à
part quelques exceptions personne ne
veut laisser embiez t sur son domaine
charitable mais ceux ci devraient
changer les sacs de nourriture sont
destinées en priorité aux malheureux de
cas bong et aux populations du nord
inaccessible par la route
seuls aliments disponibles pour le
moment du maïs est un peu de farine que
l'on garde précieusement pour les
enfants les des rotations des deux
engins ont permis d'apporter en une
seule journée plus de cinq tonnes de
vivres
aujourd'hui pour la première fois la
mission consiste à monter bien au nord
de kaboul
tout près de la frontière sud du soudan
et du kenya dans cette région les
missionnaires enfin consulté par les
responsables des opérations ont indiqué
que dans la montagne
la situation était souvent
catastrophique et que le seul moyen
d'apporter assistance jusqu'à présent
était de partir à pied avec quelques
porteurs mais j'avais rencontré avec
philippe gassot serez liane qui avait
impressionné beaucoup les testeurs
français équipe est venue dans antenne
de midi 5 août et bien elle nous a dit
tout à l'heure par téléphone la version
2000 lettres
la plupart du temps accompagnés de
chaque souvent modestes mais de chèques
pour donc ces populations affamées des
de l'ouganda lent on a envie de savoir
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement pendant ce
temps là on l'a vu à les flux d'air sous
le vent et à renwez est ce qui n'est pas
arrivé un petit peu tard les français
veulent pas l'arrivée un petit peu
l'aide française a été opérationnelle
le 19 conte très peu de temps après la
décision prise
or on peut dire aujourd'hui que c'était
elle a été adaptée aux besoins et
efficace si les sens elle a été adaptée
pense qu'elle a consisté d'abord dans
deux shows une aide médicale il faut
savoir que si la famille fait les
ravages qu'ont c'est à partir d'un
certain stade c'est par la maladie
qu'elle se manifeste et que les enfants
qu'on a vu dans ces spectacles terrible
ces enfants ne peuvent pas être alimenté
de façon normale
il leur faut un traitement médical nous
avons donc envoyé les ses rendements
les alimentations spéciale qui compte en
grande quantité et nous avons envoyé les
moyens de transport
ce que disait tout à l'heure votre
reportage images qu'on monterait indique
que jusqu'à vous et avant l'arrivée des
hélicoptères français
c'était médical ne parvenait pas dans
les endroits qui étaient recul et
distant aux la sécurité empêchaient tout
convois normaux d'arrivée nous avons
donc que je crois fait ce qu'il fallait
quand vous dites ça lui est arrivé un
peu tard peut-être on arrive toujours
trop tard mais je crois que nous avons
là il faut savoir que ces deux
hélicoptères amené par avion avec 40
minutes quel français pour les services
pour les réparer avec une réserve
d'essence ça représente un effort
considère pas ce qu'on veut pas aller
plus loin en laissant par exemple le
plateau propre et en français pour des
cons ences de longs mois que ce pays se
restaurent si je sais tout à fait notre
attention vous avez raison en réalité ce
que nous avons fait ce que je viens de
décrire cette aide médicale c'est la
première femme notre ce programme
il ya une seconde phase elle aussi le
local c'est la phase de la vaccination
qu'on ne peut pas administré à des
populations trop affaiblie et qui va
commencer dans quelques zones en
particulier vaccination contre la
rougeole qui est compte tenu de l'état
de la population le mal le plus
dangereux
naturellement aussi bcg peu leur ensuite
arriveront nos vivres 3000 tonnes de
maïs
il faut savoir qu'à l'heure actuelle il
existe à la fois quelques maigres
récoltes quelques stocks alimentaires et
que par conséquent ce n'est pas la
disponibilité de denrées alimentaires
qui manquent
et puis ensuite viendra la troisième
phase celle à laquelle vous faites et
qui consiste à remettre les caramels
jeunes au travail agricole
qu'est ce que nous ferons pour ça nous
allons leur envoyer des experts
agricoles du service national
spécialiste en irrigation avec une
quarantaine de pompe
il faut savoir les fêtes il ya des
ressources une nappe phréatique facile à
exploiter et nous allons donc tenter de
remettre au travail ces populations
agricoles pour lui permettre de survenir
elle même à ses besoins quand nous
étions mis fin juin de la base du cara
modja beaucoup de téléscripteur nous
avait écrit très très ému et et en nous
envoyant leurs contributions en disant
souvent avec lui pas lié à un petit peu
les déficits des gouvernements on n'a
pas compris pourquoi les jeunes à faire
pareil tous les gouvernements une espèce
de communauté nationale ne se réunisse
et pas pour envoyer une photo d'eux le
commando humanitaire qui puisse aider à
la résorption de la mine
je veux d'abord dire vous avez raison
dans ce qui s'est passé dans l'être il y
à la partie publique sur le gouvernement
a fait le lien de l'écrit mais il ya la
partie privée les organisations
charitables mezzagno hôpital sans
frontières médecins sans frontières
l'ordre de la croix rousse qui avait que
le 25 médecins infirmières dans des
conditions très difficiles et avec un
dévouement exemple paient de leur
personne il m'a complètement cette
action comme je viens de le dire je
trouve qu'il est assez bon que il dit se
manifeste ainsi le geste spontané des
populations qui elles visent bien pour
venir en aide
mais vous avez raison c'est qu'il faut
faire plus au plan des gouvernements et
c'est ce que j'ai proposé aux
nations-unies le coeur a ses raisons
parfois la politique n'a pas est ce que
vous n'avez pas été content la
circonstance de prendre pied dans
l'afrique
on doit non et je crois que ceci nous
avons nous avons à faire face
un drame humain nous n'avons pensé qu'à
celui là nous avons depuis longtemps
bien entendu une politique qui consiste
à affirmer la présence de la france dans
l'ensemble de l'afrique
ceci n'a rien avec ce qui a été fait
mais ce que nous suggérons c'est que au
plan mondial comme vous le suggérez vous
mêmes nous fassions plus grands efforts
pour faire face à ces situations de
misère à la fois en accroissant les
réserves alimentaires en créant une
force de transport dont nous mesurons
bien en ouganda combien est un effort
alimentaire et agricole à long terme qui
est indispensable si nous voulons
combattre la pauvreté et la faim à
nantes
dernière question être un peu simpliste
mais les raisonnements sont parfois
entre vous sommes vos mini des ailerons
chair est ce que vos préférences une
opération style colle ou eysines
opération style ou grandeur je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse mais même là comment
vous le faites sous la forme d'un choix
je voudrais qu'elles sont l'une et
l'autre nécessaire dans un cas il
s'agissait de sauver des vies menacées
par la violence dans l'autre il s'agit
de sauver des vies ne s'est pas la
pauvreté par la fin nous devons
intervenir en lin et dans l'autre de ses
doutes et nous l'avons fait merci
d'avoir été notre invité à l'étranger
toujours le coup de grogne du présent à
public iranienne monsieur bani sadr par
le nouveau cabinet que lui propose le
premier ministre et qui ne comprend plus
par exemple segunda b qui jusqu'àlors et
ministre des affaires étrangères selon
ailleurs se réjouit moscou le chef de
l'état l'a fait savoir en écrivant au
parlement et puis du nouveau peut-être
dans l' enquête sur l'attentât de
bologne on dit maintenant que les
auteurs de cet acte criminel serait bien
parmi les personnalités d'extrême droite
arrêté c'est là aussi pour nous
l'occasion de faire le point sur cet
événement marquant de l'été vite aux
roms
je serais parti d'ici de la prison de
regina szczesny de rome un des plus de
droit commun s'est confessé j'ai été
contacté par deux prisonniers néo
fasciste qui m'ont demandé de
transmettre les explosifs comme je
pouvais sortir de temps en temps de la
prison j'ai effectivement transmis ses
explosifs un certain francesco follo ti
un jeune homme de 26 ans
c'est lui qui a fait sauter la gare de
bologne les enquêteurs se renseigne
francesco follo petit
est un militant néo fasciste en somme
est ce que un mois après cet attentat la
police italienne a effectivement réussi
à mettre la main sur l'auteur de cet
horrible massacre
un mois après ce qui frappe en tout cas
c'est le côté inutile absurde de cet
attentat on a tué 84 personnes
et puis après les organisateurs et y
aurait parmi eux deux professeurs
d'université
les organisateurs espèrent est il que
ces 84 morts provoqué un changement un
bouleversement politique en italie
la police a arrêté 19 personnes qui
seraient les organisateurs et les
exécuteurs du massacre de bologne
peut-être que les néofascistes voulait
montrer après quelques années de silence
il n'y a pas que les brigades rouges en
italie qu'il y à aussi un terrorisme
noir avec lequel il faut compter bien
mais à quoi mène ce terrorisme qu'il
soit rouge noir à rien
malheureusement ici en italie on est
entré dans une espèce de routine du
terrorisme puisqu'il est fort possible
que les brigades rouges reprennent leurs
activités à la rentrée au mois de
septembre la chaîne française maintenant
avec toujours en première place le
conflit de la pêche aujourd'hui nette
détente une journée décisive demain avec
une troisième réunion de la commission
nationale de conciliation
il va donc se réunir sous les auspices
du directeur général la marine marchande
et qui va réunir armateurs et marin
pêcheur un millier d'entre eux ont
d'ailleurs ceux de port en bessin
basse-normandie projeté de participer à
une marche demain à paris par ailleurs
la cgt a lancé toujours pour demain mot
d'ordre de grève que ne suivra pas la
cible
aujourd'hui les négociations avaient
repris à boulogne le travail a repris
également à arcachon et à étapes mais la
grève se poursuit à concarneau est alors
gens là encore je crois que pour les
vacanciers d'août c'est une occasion de
se rafraîchir la mémoire sur les racines
de ce conflit
tout est parti d'ici à boulogne d'un
conflit puis l'a fait classique et
formateur en difficulté financière
décide de réduire le nombre des marins
sur les chalutiers pour équilibrer
l'économie style
il faut ramener les équipages de 20
2 à 18 heures le conflit est de portée
limitée cette décision menace de
licenciement entre 120 et 150 marins
pêcheurs mais à boulogne déjà fortement
touchée par le chômage
les syndicats réagissent vivement le 29
juillet il décide de bloquer le port
très vite le prix des carburants qui a
doublé en un an vient au centre du
conflit armateurs et syndicats réclament
de l'état une aide aux ghazal la réponse
du ministre des transports est
catégorique la hausse du coût du prix
d'énergie fera toute l'économie
il faut aussi adapter par une nouvelle
organisation et non par des subsides
deuxième temps du conflit le 13 août les
artisans pêcheurs de basse normandie se
joignent au mouvement par solidarité
mais bientôt à port en bessin ou à
fécamp ils développent leurs propres
revendications tout en demandant eux
aussi une baisse du prix du fioul devant
la fermeté du gouvernement le conflit
s'étend de dunkerque à fos les ports les
uns après les autres sont bloqués
les syndicats montent d'un cran leur
revendication ils réclament une
négociation globale au plan national
pour le gouvernement les problèmes de la
pêche ont des problèmes internes à une
profession et qui appellent des
solutions cas par cas or par pas les
premières négociations dans les
instances nationales n'aboutissent pas
et le 20 août le premier ministre tape
du poing sur la table la marine de
guerre interviendra ce le faut pour
rétablir l'accès du parc être vous
menace aussitôt mise à exécution
d'abord à force puis antifer ou une
étonnante batailles navales de plusieurs
heurts opposent à royal aux chalutiers
plusieurs blessés à fos de sérieux
dégâts matériels pour les chalutiers
diar ici a envie faire un nouveau pas
est franchi dans ce conflit qui dure
déjà depuis près d'un mois
le lendemain monsieur le theule présente
ces mesures elles sont surtout destinés
à la pêche artisanale est financière
l'aider à se moderniser dispositions
réglementaires pour améliorer les
circuits de vente et meilleur contrôle
des importations mais pas question de
toucher au carbure le conflit alors se
cristallise à boulogne complètement
isolé pendant
plusieurs jours mais mardi dernier des
négociations reprend au ministère de la
marine marchande
le dialogue est rétabli et se poursuivra
par nouvelle réunion demain et puis
demain toujours à l'assemblée nationale
la réunion du groupe d'étude de la mer
qui sera boycotté par les communistes
dit avoir appris la réunion par boîte
politique toujours robert fabre chez
raymond barre cet après midi à montbard
qui avait le matin fêter le
cinquantenaire de la traversée de costes
et bellonte au dessus de l'atlantique
le premier ministre aux côtés de
bellande vous voyez en a profité pour
rendre un hommage à ceux qui ont assuré
et qui assure aujourd'hui encore la
vitalité de l'info nautique français
c'était au bourget enfin manufrance avec
l'intervention de la cgt aujourd'hui une
lettre de jean resseguie à raymond barre
et la décision de la montée de
l'intersyndicale sur paris jeudi les
sports maintenant ce n'est
malheureusement pas de nouvelles à vous
donner une dynamique noah qui affronte
gun board en ce moment même le match
devraient avoir commencé pors mcenroe
vous le savez c'est pour demain vous
avez pu assister à la qualification de
vilas en direct sur antenne 2 cet après
midi pas de nouvelles non plus de la
coupe america il y en principe une
régate aujourd'hui qui devrait se courir
là également en ce moment même en tout
cas dans les minutes à venir mais je
vous rappelle que france 3 est toujours
mené 2 à 0 par son concurrent
non monsieur pourquoi il s'est vu le
drapeau français tous les matins c'est
un petit geste un petit geste d'amitié
envers en ce froid et la france j'aime
les français
et puis j'ai de l'estimé pour ce baron
bich
chaque jour depuis le début de la finale
du challenger les français vérifie d'un
regard ce paradoxe un bateau américain
petit frère du tenant de l'américain
coop les encourage drapeau
bleu-blanc-rouge pauvres quelques
minutes avant le départ de la deuxième
régate le barreur de france 3 est
inquiet bruno troublé en effet dispute
pour la première fois l'américain sur
l'australien a par contre j mardi
demeure serein c'est sa troisième
participation dans cette épreuve
le bleu français apprend vite très vite
selon les observateurs
mais il ya l'expérience de 10 marty et
il a réussi ni barreur australien
verdict australien emporte la deuxième
régate avec 40 secondes à vence pour
l'architecte le france 3 les qualités du
bateau ne sont pas la raison de la
défaite des français
les deux bateaux vont aussi vite l'un
que l'autre
ils pensent doivent concentrer près en
vitesse vraiment trop près je pense
c'était l'impression qu'on me déchirait
les transports et
il faut qu'à un petit plus vite sur leur
parcours
comment expliquer aujourd'hui la
nouvelle défaite de france 3
moi je trouve dans la première cinq
minutes après le départ on
c'est la décision possible que correcte
et on peine à régater problème tactique
donc pour france 3 au cours de la
troisième régate si les français ne
parviennent pas à partir plus vite que
les australiens alors le rêve d'un vieux
monsieur un rêve de 12 hors d'âge sera
très compromis un début de réponse dans
le rôle de paul amar 23 heures ainsi que
le résultat du match bordeaux contre
noah le temps pour terminer bien le sera
généralement ensoleillé après la
disparition des brouillards matinaux qui
seront assez nombreux dans l'intérieur
la matinée sera fraîche mais les
températures maximales s'élèveront un
petit peu nous dit la météo malgré la
présence de nuages l'après midi sur les
régions situées au nord de la loire
là c'était la carte il attend des
températures d'aujourd'hui le vent sera
faible en général mais encore assez
faible quand même dans la vallée du
rhône font appel question de temps à
20h30 donc tout de suite après la page
de publicité sur la pologne
paul amar vers 22h50 et puis antenne
2010 demain avec patrick lecocq et
gilbert bécaud sont invités bonsoir à
demain